[Music]
some spectacular crashes at this year's
Winter Olympics are raising questions
about whether the games are becoming too
dangerous
one example happened last week when a 16
year old Japanese snowboarder suffered a
scary collision in the halfpipe
competition he avoided major injury Dana
Jacobson is in Pyeongchang to explain
why some believe the Olympics are
pushing the limits too far Dana good
morning good morning Sean white first
won Olympic gold with back-to-back
Tenet's that's three revolutions in the
air he needed for the revolutions this
year a 1440 12 years later in order to
get the gold it's also the same trick
that are them sixty two stitches during
a practice crash so have they pushed the
boundaries now too far broke my jaw
really bad in two places ruptured spleen
collapsed lung bruised heart after
nearly dying last year in a backcountry
snowboarding accident
Mark McMorris feels lucky to do what he
loves most catching air and soaking in
what he calls ultimate joy what is the
first thing you remember from after the
accident when they took me out of the
coma and everybody is standing there I
can talk but they gave me a pen and
paper and I wrote do I have brain damage
and can I go to the Olympics still not
only did McMorris make it to the
Olympics he's the snowboard slopestyle
bronze medalist it was really scary to
start trying some of those tricks again
but I just need to remind myself and I
got hurt in the backcountry hitting a
tree I didn't get hurt trying those
crazy tricks the Winter Olympics have
most definitely gotten more dangerous
historian David Wallace n ski has
attended every Winter Games since 1992
let's face it it's good TV to see people
risking their their health their lives
his great television sorry the British
Journal of Sports Medicine studied the
2014 Sochi Olympics and found that
nearly 49 percent of all aerial skiers
in those games suffered an injury many
of the most dangerous sports according
to the study are extreme sports which
made their Olympics debut in 2006 the
International Olympics
several years ago decided that they were
losing the youth audience not a lot of
Americans watched biathlon but they will
watch snowboarding and so they just kept
adding these I think they're gonna get
harder and harder until at some point
somebody suffers a complete paralysis
during an Olympic event or actually dies
24 year-old Mark McMorris says his sport
has skyrocketed in complexity since he
started competing but he doesn't believe
his sport should change every sport has
a lot of danger I think just because
we're an extreme sport it seems a little
crazier and everybody's eyes
bottom line Mark McMorris says it is his
passion for his sport that drives him to
keep trying new tricks and we should
point out there has never been a death
during Olympic competition our request
to the IOC for comment went unanswered
Gayle all right Dana Jacobson thank you